from accusations of being too woke to a
cheap joke about a serious women's
movement both sides of the aisle are up
in arms over Velma here's why the HBO
animated series can't make anyone happy
whenever a franchise with an established
fandom gets a new entry there tends to
be plenty of detractors who struggle to
accept their beloved characters being
completely reimagined but unlike the
backlash from other well-established
fandoms the response to Velma seems to
be uniting many disparate groups of
viewers in their dislike typically
reimagined shows catch a lot of hate
because of their Divergence from The
Source material however Velma has taken
Flack for a variety of reasons slate
cited the show's adherence to the cash
grab streamer formula the outlet noted
this formula entails rebooting major IP
darkening the tone of a beloved
children's franchise and attempting the
ewokification of older franchises
additionally groups like The
fundamentalist Christian group 1 million
moms railed against the series however
for every critic and audience member
that blasted the show as too woke
another spoke up to claim the show is
openly mocking wokeness Forbes even
reported on a theory that Mindy Kaling
the voice of Velma and an executive
producer created the show to parody
progressives though the writer of the
piece didn't buy into it writing I'm not
sure I subscribed to this Mindy Kaling
made a dog whistle series for right-wing
trolls Theory as the Occam's razor
explanation is that the show is just bad
while the theory that Mindy Kaling
created Velma as a way to subtly mock
the left and arm the right is
far-fetched to say the least some have
pointed to past controversies involving
the comedian as proof that she's not as
Progressive as many of her peers in
Hollywood kaling's Memoir is everyone
hanging out without me it was deemed
defensive and insensitive by some
reviewers viewers have claimed that
kaling's comedic repertoire often makes
light of negative South Asian
stereotypes mocks South Asian culture
and features a South Asian protagonist
with an extreme attraction to white men
and that Velma is no different others
have flat out accused Kaling of hating
her Heritage but women's Republic
founder Sai sashaadri tweeted did two
days after Velma premiered I'm happy
Mindy kaling's style of riding brown
girls that hate themselves wasn't around
when I was younger and only became a
thing when I was at the age where I
loved my Heritage and skin color as the
rap observed kaling's character on The
Mindy Project was exclusively paired
with white men a complaint the writer
dismissed while speaking with
Entertainment Weekly she said do people
really wonder on other shows if female
leads are dating Multicultural people
like I owe it to every race and minority
and beleaguered person although Velma
features a few Central characters from
the Scooby-Doo franchise it's hard not
to notice the very prominent absence of
the linguistically gifted Great Dane
himself in absence that many fans of the
franchise find hard to swallow Scooby
Doo more like Scooby don't speaking to
TV Insider Kaling expressed her and
showrunner Charlie Grandy's mutual love
for the original Scooby-Doo as well as
their gratitude for Warner Brothers
allowing them to modernize certain
elements of the property according to
grandi Kaling approached him about
developing an origin story for the
Mystery Inc gang something he jumped at
however while Warner Brothers were okay
with her developing Velma the Studio's
blessing came with a caveat no dogs
allowed Grandy addressed the canine's
absence during a New York Comic-Con
panel explaining that Warner Brothers
explicitly refused to Grant HBO the
rights to use Scooby-Doo for the series
degrandy this was an acceptable loss
since he and Kaling intended the series
to be an adult animation anyway Grandy
said on the panel we couldn't get a take
on it that was like how do we kind of do
this in a fun modern way we felt like
what made it a kid's show was Scooby-Doo
by going into the gang's life before
they met the franchise's titular Pooch
they were able to solve the canine
conundrum however for the fans many of
whom feel that scoop is the heart and
soul of the sleuth Circle the dog's
absence is hard to overlook in a world
where whitewashing has been the standard
for far too long changing the race of a
character or a race bending as it's
often referred to is a way to broaden
minority representation on the screen
when done well these changes allow for
an insightful reimagining of a character
but does Velma it right on the surface
it seems like Velma takes a positive
step in changing the races of three main
characters besides reimagining its
titular character as an American of
South Asian descent the show changes
Daphne to Asian and has Shaggy who goes
by his actual name Norville as black I
we're just breaking barriers on the show
however the response to this went down
poorly on both sides of the political
divide right-wing comic Leo kierce
called the show openly racist against
white people in an article for the
Scottish Daily Telegraph pointing to the
fact that Fred seems to always be the
butt of the joke yet many people who are
in favor of more diversity were also
disappointed and called the show out for
being racist in its new depictions of
Velma Daphne and Shaggy one person wrote
on Reddit it's been a joke that Shaggy's
a stoner for the past couple of decades
they took the stoner cast a black actor
and redesigned him to be black Daphne
has been consistently depicted as a rich
socialite making her a rich Asian is
just another stereotype the Reddit post
goes on to lament the fact that the
creators made Velma a South Asian
character a whiz with computers dubbing
the show a smorgasbord of stereotypes
part of what makes Scooby Do so
endearing are The Lovable characters in
their chemistry although each of the
main characters superficially fits a
stereotype their personalities are all
pretty likable and come together
perfectly in a way that lets them all be
more than their label like all good
friend groups they're Simply Better
Together while every incarnation of the
gang tweaks their personality slightly
each iteration somehow manages to
maintain the same core chemistry and
charm that is many fans assert until
Velma came along many viewers simply
don't like the show's incessantly
cynical lead character Velma who spends
most of her time dragging her classmates
and anyone else with The Misfortune to
cross her path within the first five
minutes of the pilot she physically
attacks an unarmed Daphne calling her a
and stupid when she becomes a
person of interest in Brenda's murder
her dad reminds her she was voted most
revengey while the original Fred was a
likable fellow with a borderline
obsessive love of traps the Fred and
Velma is a narcissistic barely
functional rich kid who can't remember
Velma from one interaction to the next
and then there's Daphne the ultimate
mean girl who calls Velma Vermin and
demands 500 in exchange for velma's
Mom's cold case File Norville is
arguably the most likable among the four
but the fact that he spends most of his
time pining for Velma is a bitter pill
for OG Shaggy fans as a character Velma
has long been seen as a lesbian icon
many people involved with various new
takes on the character hinted at it over
the years and velma's sexuality finally
became canon in the 2022 film
trick-or-treat Scooby-Doo to many fans
the idea that Velma would be gay in her
latest iteration seems to naturally
follow her long history of queerness and
yet many feel that Velma failed in its
representation of the Beloved
character's identity engaging in what is
often referred to as queerbaiting
hinting at a queer relationship
developing but not seeing it through at
the show's outset Velma is obsessed not
with Daphne but Fred which may seem an
odd choice for the brainy gal while it
makes sense that this early Velma would
be in the process of exploring her
sexuality her quick shift from crushing
on Fred to getting red-faced over Daphne
after the two share a kiss seems
performative and unearned to some
viewers given the fact that they start
out as enemies of all the controversial
things about Velma the biggest of the
bunch has to be the joke that pokes fun
at the metoo movement in the episode The
Candy woman Velma tells Daphne I spit
truth without a filter like every
comedian before hashtag metoo it was The
Mindy Kaling mic drop heard around the
world or at least all over Twitter
reactions came pouring in many of them
angry others confused one user wrote the
fact that Velma goes from weird
transphobic jokes in the same episode
mocking how comedy shifted after metoo
to Woe guys diversity win has officially
made this the first ever show without a
demographic to appeal to it's a joke
that looks even worse when juxtaposed
against a throwaway line from episode 1
in which one of Daphne's cop moms tells
Velma her and you were lurking around
the showers like a gym teacher who isn't
a gym teacher anymore
although the argument could be made that
velma's take on me too is just another
example of her need for growth going
down this route is not a good look for
the show
it's hard to believe that fourth wall
breaking was once rare this type of
self-referential or meta humor served as
a device for examining or even
subverting a genre's use of tropes and
was integral to the comedy writing of
shows like Arrested Development and
Community unfortunately the Trope has
seen a rise in usage that veers into
cliche territory showing up in
everything from children's films to
laugh tracks sitcoms increasingly
audiences are reporting a kind of
meta-fatigue as they Tire of the oft
formulaic insertion of referential jokes
that add little to the writing and
perhaps because it's such an easy
formula to write Velma makes abundant
use of this joke writing strategy much
to the Chagrin of some viewers the
Relentless meta-humor begins moments
into the series when Velma ruminates on
Origin stories and continues through the
first scene with Daphne's Proclamation
that have you ever noticed how pilot
episodes of TV shows always have more
gratuitous sex and nudity than the rest
of the series
as Steve reviews lamented you can't go
more than two minutes without the show
trying to show off how clever and
self-aware it is from lines like what
would happen if this was a show to
explicit discussions of the TV Trope the
animation is currently referencing
there's a lot of meta humor although
cracked reminds detractors that
Scooby-Doo has always been meta and
reviews from the likes of collider found
this writing subversively hilarious many
feel meta humor is best when used
sparingly despite the show's poor
reception many viewers have praised the
animators responsible for Velma as an
adult animated series it's to be
expected that the show would redesign
the Mystery Machine universe that shows
stylistic appearance may feel familiar
to fans of other contemporary adult
animations like HBO's Harley Quinn for
example there is no denying that Velma
is a treat to look at with fans praising
the art despite the show's other
shortcomings and although there aren't
nearly enough of them Velma also
contains beautiful rendered depictions
of the titular character hallucinating
dark psychedelic Visions as she veers
into mystery-solving territory however
aside from these trippy scenes most of
the animation surrounds some pretty
straightforward storytelling that
doesn't allow much room for Creative
license some viewers also observed that
the writing and animation teams struggle
to sync up their intentions as Quentin
reviews noted the animators incorporate
pop culture references that aren't
supported by the acting or storytelling
tweeting the main cop in the show is
visually based on Don Knotts a famous
guest in the original show but his voice
isn't while it's clear the animators
understood their Source material these
gaps in storytelling have caused many to
question the authenticity of the
showrunner's relationship to the source
material
foreign